je m'appelle Sarah j'ai 12 ans et à
l'école est dans la rue on mettra des
saltêtes et de caméléons et je trouve
que c'est injuste ça a commencé quand je
suis arrivé au collège puis ça a duré
toute l'année
ils ont commencé je l'ai déjà je les
connaissais pas ils vont commencer je
les ai jamais provoqué
c'est plus fort que moi j'arrive pas je
me vois il me disent que ils ont envie
de vomir et des trucs comme ça
est-ce que tu as l'impression d'être par
rapport aux autres enfants de l'école
d'être un cas spécial et unique
qui souffrent de ça on peut peut-être
avoir une tête de Gorée ou des trucs
comme ça mais on est toujours un humain
alors ça me ça m'énerve parce que je
suis je suis quelqu'un comme tous les
autres